David I understand you are in favor of
programs that will make public college
and university tuition free at the point
of purchase so to speak and paid through
taxation but if the cost of college goes
down including 2-0 wouldn't the demand
go way up and therefore we would need to
restrict access causing even more
problems this is a really good question
and I've talked about it before actually
so the first thing that that's really
important to understand is that this is
based on very general sort of classical
economics if something becomes free will
there not be more demand of it and also
will this not cause supply issues on the
other side in the sense that if college
becomes free instead of paid way more
people will say well if it's free then
I'm going to go causing colleges and
universities to become way more
restrictive in their admissions criteria
causing all sorts of new problems and
maybe even reducing the number of people
reducing the percentage of people who
want to go to college who are able to go
the first thing that's important to
remember is that it's not actually free
it's paid through taxes so there are
currently restrictions on supply when it
comes to college and there would still
be restrictions on supply if college
were to become quote free under a plan
like what's proposed by Bernie Sanders
and then we're talking about a matter of
degree it's really important to
understand that this is not an issue
that doesn't exist now and all of a
sudden would exist if college tuition at
public colleges and universities becomes
paid for through taxes it is true that
if college becomes more competitive it
will make some current problems worse
for example legacy admissions become
even crazier when there are
significantly more people competing for
a fixed number of spots at a college or
university and some number go to legacy
admissions who have not earned their
place beyond having parents or family
members who went there or made financial
contributions which is not even really a
legacy admission but but something else
but the most important thing that we
have to remember is that free college
doesn't mean free college forever
it means you know free Community College
for people who qualify community
colleges are often not at capacity and
they are also not going to be
interesting to everyone it means free
probably in-state public colleges if you
meet the admission standards that are
already there yes tougher standards
would would also increase restrictions
there but the other thing that needs to
come with this this type of reform and I
actually don't think it's being
discussed enough by some of the
Democratic candidates that favor it is
as a society we need to revisit how we
look at college and I think that
everybody who is saying we need to
remember that most people are still not
getting college degrees we need to
increase both both focus on and funding
of trade school it's okay that college
isn't for everybody and that has to be a
part of it that's fine to say college
should not be a participation trophy but
it also needs to be dealt with the
reality needs to be dealt with that
there are significant inequalities and
discrepancies in terms of who is getting
into college and getting college degrees
and by virtue of that getting the jobs
that are increasingly restricted to
people who have college degrees
that's an inequality and there are
discrepancies there that need to be
evened out but look at Europe as an
example in Europe there are lots of good
schools that are both extremely
affordable and relatively easy to get
into but this sort of supply-demand
chaos that some are predicting would
take place simply doesn't exist and then
on the back end of this you have to
remember something else there will be
more demand for college there will be
somewhat more demand for college and
university if it becomes tuition free
for those who can get in but what you
have to also remember is that on the
back end the United States is falling
significantly behind in many fields when
it comes to our educational level and
sort of proficiency attainment relative
to other countries by in the immediate
taking the cost of expanding the size of
some of these colleges and universities
if the increased demand warrants it on
the back end there's going to be a
significant multiplier having
more educated population is known I mean
it's widely been studied has an economic
multiplier effect which will be which
with the country will benefit from by
virtue of people earning higher wages
and thus paying more money in income
taxes etc etc and you've got to look at
all pieces of the puzzle simply saying
well if it becomes free everyone will
want it and it won't be sustainable and
it'll become insanely difficult to get
into even you know moderately
restrictive or or less restrictive
colleges you need to look at the entire
picture and that's not really being done
if you just say it's gonna create chaos
and sort of irrationally difficult
admission standards for every school and
remember that Community College doesn't
work that way if you qualify for
Community College you can just sign up
and take classes and that is
extraordinarily underutilized okay we've
got a great bonus show coming up for you
today two ways to get the bonus show
become a member at david pakman.com
slash membership become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show